born in advance for managers of research
and you talk about the two-sided
estimate for the gosh i know its ability
deficit alright thank you for the
invitation and for waking up this early
to hear the talk so the first a couple
of minutes are going to be about
explaining all the words in the title i
guess those of you who attended joe
stock yesterday should more or less
already know what it means so i'm gonna
go over it rather quickly alright so
let's try to understand what is Gaussian
noise gaseous so given to standard
Gaussian random vectors we say that they
have correlation row between them broken
in general be between minus 1 and 1 but
here it will only consider positive
correlation so this happens if
equivalently either each coordinate of x
and y so corresponding coordinates have
a jointly bivariate Gaussian
distribution with variance 1 and
correlation row or equivalently you can
think about it like this X is root Rose
time some standard Gaussian set 1 plus
root 1 over Rho times another standard
Gaussian which will think about as noise
and why is the same only the copy of the
noise will take just an independent copy
so you can think about both of them as
if Rho is a closed one then they are
more or less the same thing up to some
independent noise so we'll think about
why is a noise version of X alright what
is noised ability so given a set in our
n
the noise stability of a so we'll denote
it like that this stability sub row of a
will just be the probability that for
such x and y both x and y are in a maybe
it would make a little bit more sense to
divide this thinned by the product of
probabilities that X and ay and what and
why is in a in some sense the stability
just measures given that a Gaussian
vector is in a what's the probability
that a noise version of this vector will
still be inside a so we should think
about sets which look like this like a
cloud of many little sets is very
unstable right because if I know that X
is in a says practically nothing about
why and will soon see which sets we
should expect to be more stable or most
stable and
a theorem of Burrell which Joe already
mentioned from 85 86 state and following
hyper planes are basically the most
noise table sets in other words if H is
a hyperplane having the same gaussian
measure as that of a then the noise
stability of h must be at least as big
as the nicest ability of a half space
sorry did I also say hyperplane or I
just well this is also true for half
spaces but it's not a very clever result
all right so the best real life example
I could come up with for the application
of this is the following say you have a
large number of street cats and you're
collecting them according to some
properties which they have for example
their weight their height how hard they
a meow and all sorts of properties which
have a continuous distribution let's
assume that they have a Gaussian
distribution and if a cat is another cat
sibling or ancestor
and we assume that each one of these
genes have some correlation between them
otherwise they're all just independent
and then collecting them according to
some criteria which I determine and what
I want to do is to set the criteria such
that the expected number of cats I
collected 100 and I want to maximize the
expected number of pairs of cats which
are related by ancestry or by being
siblings what I want what I'm gonna do
in order to do that is just get some
hyper plane of of genes so if all the
genes are independent then it'll I'll
just take one property the one with the
biggest correlation and just collect all
the cats whose I don't know color is
blacker than something okay should
mention that no animals were injured in
the making of this example but you can
also take linear combinations of genes
oh yeah so if they are all independent
then assuming the correlations are not
exactly the same i'll take the gene with
the highest correlation if they are
dependent like okay basically weight and
height are usually dependent and usually
I'll take it the Maximizer will be some
linear combination okay this example is
not so important maybe we can move on
okay it will always be a linear
threshold exactly for some linear
combination of genes of properties right
okay so
Oh should you also yes so in general
Royce is is some matrix but okay if we
and and the GAO shins are not
independent but we can normalize it such
that Troy is a diagonal matrix right I
mean we can write and this is why I take
the highest value but let in in this in
this stopper assuming that row is just a
number so it's just the scalar matrix
okay so now it just it was didn't make
sense for the example to say that all
the rows are the same but let's say that
from now on the kids are such that for
jeans at the same correlation all right
so one could hope to find okay maybe
before I move on I want to comment that
this theorem also implies the so-called
isoparametric and quality for the oceans
it follows from the fact that if we take
the limit row going to one so the noise
is very very small and I have the set a
which looks like this then the
probability that X is in a and why is in
the complement of a well it will be very
small one row is close to one but we can
consider the derivative with respect to
Road there is actually no derivative but
if we not normalize by the square root
it turns out that this looks more or
less like the root of 1 minus Rho times
the surface area
of a and when I say surface area I don't
want to do the afterward definition but
it's the Gaussian surface area so i
integrate the Gaussian density over the
surface area measure of the boundary of
a so one row is close to 1 it's pretty
easy to imagine or to at least agree
more or less that well the the
probability that i'll have one point
here in one point outside of a is
proportional to that Gaussian surface
area right so if i take the limit at 1i
recover a result initially proven again
by poor Ellen independently by sue the
covin Saracen stating that hyper planes
minimize the surface area now it seems
pretty natural to ask if there is some
kind of stability result for this
Gaussian noise stability now since we
are already using the word stability
let's ask if there is some robustness
for this inequality meaning that okay we
know that hyper planes maximize that but
can we say something about a set that
almost maximizes this so can we say that
given
given that the deficit between these two
things is rather small
maybe a looks more or less like a
hyperplane in some sense a half space
yeah so when I make a mistake once I
tend to make it again and again so maybe
when i say hyperplane from now on if you
understand this is half space all right
so maybe well this implies that I mean I
haven't really formulated what this is
but a reasonable formulation would imply
that well any quality can happen here
only if those sets are half spaces and
moreover if there is almost an equality
than in some sense we should expect the
set to be almost a half space so this
was initially verified by alpha and
muscle and Joe Neiman I will soon a stay
there exact results but first of all
let's think what natural metrics one
could use in order to compare set to the
closest have space to it so it guess one
natural metric we could consider is just
the total variation distance let's
define for set a delta of a to be the
minimum over all possible half spaces h
prime
such that the Gaussian measures of H
Prime and a are the same of the Gaussian
probability of the symmetric difference
between a and H prime so forceps I look
at so if it if this is the set a then I
kind of try to find the half space which
minimizes the measure these things then
I look at their elgin measure theorem
of elfin and Joe from of 2012 says the
following up to some constant that
depends on the measure of a and enroll
we know that this delta taken to the
power 4 is smaller or equal than the
deficits
and here and always them in this talk
I'm assuming that H is such that the the
ocean measure of h is equal to the
Gaussian measure this is almost a key
right there is some plus epsilon here
but ok it I don't wanna exactly so this
is almost exact formulation and well yes
actually a functional version is
equivalent you can sum of all one
dimension up just add another dimension
and consider the fat as the level set to
function and yet more or less the same
now let's go back to burbs inequality I
so since there are many experts here for
applications of this I I want a
one-state any applications I'll just
briefly say that this was initially used
in the paper by muscle O'Donnell and
polish carriage in order to prove the
discrete analogue called majority's stay
blessed it also has applications confirm
for finding max cut algorithms and many
other applications this theorem actually
gives robustness a robust version for
all such applications so one example of
a consequence of this theorem is a
robustness for the majority stay blessed
theorem meaning that in the discrete
version under the assumption of low
influences a subset of the cube that has
a noise stability close to the one of
majority actually is actually close to
the majority set or function
and they just want okay I i just want to
mention that another corollary of this
under some additional assumptions is a
robust version of the Gaussian
isoparametric inequality so taking the
limit row goes to 1 and this could be
done only if this constant has a nice
behavior with dependence on row so this
is based on an idea of michela do one
can apply this thing to get a
corresponding robust version for the
Gaussian isoparametric inequality namely
if you have set whose surface area is
close to the one of the corresponding
half space then the set will be close to
a half space now in the same I think it
was written in the paper so the
conjectured that this constant for can
be replaced by the constant to will
address this conjecture later but before
we do this I want to try to convince you
that maybe this metric is not the best
metric to measure the distance between a
second and the corresponding GAAP spaces
and the reason is the followed so let's
consider some half space age and let's
think about two possible perturbations
of this half space the first one is I
take a little straight from here whose
couch and measure is epsilon and I just
move it over here
so it delete this and I put a strip here
of measure website on so this is the
first perturbation and the second one is
the following I take the same strip this
one I also delete it but instead of
putting it here I put it somewhere
farther away so say it's called constant
distance so let's call the let's call h
minus the strip h 1 this will be s 1 and
now we take again h1 but we add instead
of s1 we add s2 which is a strip of the
same gaussian measure but far away let's
say a distance one instead of here it
would be distance of order website so
this is s 2 and this is the second
perturbation and
so fight between the inner space isn't
expressing at some point if you go too
far away give you another spaces well
there are a lot of moms but no it's like
yeah yeah I fits the measure to be
epsilon so yeah yeah okay I don't see
why it would because they even the
entire half half space will have
measureless an epson it means what she
paid will become a house but you look oh
ok ok all right then you yeah you cannot
move this but everything go together
would not be upset this room now what
they claim is the following conditioning
when the fact that ex-felon s1 the
probability that y felin h1 is almost
the same as the probability that Y fell
in h1 conditioned on X falling in the
original strip which are removed let's
call it s0 what do I mean almost almost
up to something which is of order
epsilon right because they only moved X
by epsilon on the other hand
conditioning on X falling in s2 the
probability of Y falling in h1 is well
it's some constant strictly smaller than
1 times the probability that Y falls in
h1 conditioning 1x falling in s0 so
this is what I'm saying if i compare
these three fence
then I claim that this is equal to this
up to something of order epsilon and on
the other end if I compare it to this
this is actually much smaller so it's
smaller equal to this some time some
even if it's time some points that one
plus C C strictly bigger than 0 and it's
independent of the title and this means
that the stability of the first set well
what is it so it's the probability that
both X and wiring h1 plus twice the
probability that x is an s 200 sorry
this is one twice the probability that X
is in s1 and wise here plus something of
the order epsilon square which is the
probability that both fall in s1 so I
claim that this is something like the
stability of the original then my minus
something of the order silence where I'm
just because i have this epsilon of this
is the probability that one of them will
even fall in either s1 or s2 and if they
fall in s1 i only get loose and epsilon
but the probability but the stability of
two well this is the stability of age
time something of the order at least
epsilon now both of these sets of the
same total variation distance from age
so I can't hope I mean there is
definitely something they're not
capturing when I'm considering only the
total variation distance so one may hope
for a metric that gives us some more
information and the theorem I want to
talk about is the following Oh
if I define the following matrix so
instead of Delta of a let's consider the
metric epsilon of a defined by we take
this the Gaussian centroid of H so H is
just again any half space with the
option measure is the same as that of a
and they look how far it is from the
origin and i subtract the norm of the
Gaussian centroid of a if I want those
ready to be sent roids I have to divide
by the volume but it doesn't matter so
much here I claim that this metric does
capture the difference between these two
things right because it measures how
much mass I moved and also how far I
moved it from where it originally was
these this will be order epsilon square
here and this will be ordered Cylon if I
look at ya this is already called
epsilon but yes it's okay and the
theorem that we get is the following so
if i consider the same deficit
it can be bounded actually from both
below and above by essentially almost
the same quantity so you have your
constant dependent on the measure of a
and dro times epsilon of a and hear the
same thing with a different constant
unfortunately we don't get exactly this
we get this with a logarithmic
correction so on this side I also have
so this is times the logarithm of
epsilon of a minus 1 absolute well yes
yes s that that's the only that's the
only right but but if I turn H around
the distant just the modulo of the
central it doesn't change right I mean I
look at the half space and I turn it
right but i think i take the norm of the
mean okay it's definitely natural if i
have set a to look at the h whose norm
is in the same direction is that of a so
this will be the centroid of age and
this will be the centroid of a it's not
hard to see that the centroid of H is
always farther away from the origin
which is say here all right and then and
then this distance just measures how
much mass and how far away had to push
it
w distance I was just trying ahh the
restriction restriction to H yeah so
well yes it is related but not exactly
that that's actually a very good
question but I like it can I touch it I
actually wanted to touch it a little bit
later so i think the metric that you now
mansion is in in some sense even even
better okay but it's kind of harder to
approach proof wise okay okay so it took
me a bit longer than i expected to do so
that was the introductory part and what
I'll do from now on is give some ideas
of the proof mainly focusing get on
trying to convince you that this
quantity is very natural or not not only
because it captures more but also
because it appears in a very natural way
relating to a Gaussian noise stability
yes oh right yeah thank you thank you so
11 so to corollaries of this
so the first corollary is that the
conjecture that this conjecture is
verified up to a logarithmic term so
actually delta square of a is all always
smaller equal to epsilon of a up to some
constant i don't know 10 so if i just
plug this in this verifies this
conjecture but basically the this
inequality is an equality in this case
this is some of the worst case and the
second corollary is well again using
michela dues methods and taking growth
one the dependence of on row in this
constant is good enough to get a robust
version of galvanized upper imagery and
i don't want to stay the exact theorem
but basically you can imagine what kind
of i don't remember if I mentioned this
this only this is not the first robust
version it it improves the certain
result of the result of Ellen and Jo and
there was actually another result by
guys whose names I don't remember which
give another in some senses way currents
other senses stronger isoparametric
result all right
so let's try to see some ideas from the
proof first of all if I want to look at
the stability of a set a this is equal
let's go back to the definition it's the
probability that x and y are in a and if
you remember i could define x and y as
square root of rho times some gaussians
at 1 plus root 1 1 minus rho times an
independent Gaussian so this was X and
why was the first term term was the same
and the second was just an independent
copy so that one's a twin set free are
just independent standard gaussians and
definitely what I can do is the
following gate I can take expectation
over z1 and conditioned on that one
inside this probability this obviously
doesn't change anything now once I
conditioned on that one note that these
two things become independent right so
now that they are independent what I can
do is just erase one of them and put
square here
right now what we do now is we take let
WTB a standard Brownian motion it's
clear that well w at time row has the
distribution of square root of Rho times
that one right and the Joint
Distribution of W time row and W time
one is the same joint distribution as
square root row of Z 1 and square root
rosette 1 plus root 1 minus ro z to
write because W 1 minus w ro is an
independent Gaussian so this would
actually be root 1 minus Rosie too which
means that I can go back here and say
that the noise stability of a is just
the probability that w 1 is an a
conditioned on w Rho square expectation
what I did is replace this with w1 and
well this with WR 0 and therefore it
seems kind of natural to define the dube
martingale empty to be the probability
that the Brownian motion at time one is
in a conditioned on the filtration at
time T so if you're uncomfortable
table with the filtration we condition
at w1w a time T here and what we get is
that s row of a the quantity we're
interested in is just the expectation of
this martingale taken a time Rho square
right how many of you feel a little bit
uncomfortable with Ito's formula no no
how many really really have no idea what
okay the little ball I mean a little or
more yes yeah that that kind of 20 of
people okay um all right so really
briefly so this thing is a martingale
obviously it's a doob martingale any
martingale i can write as follows so i
can write empty to be the integral
between 0 and t of some process sigma
taking it some s saying how fast empty
is variant it is varying times the
increment of some Brownian motion and if
you're uncomfortable with this thing
just imagine it as plus minus 1 times
the root of d s just fix s to be des to
be very small and take here independent
Bernoulli increment and well this is a
very very maybe the most basic
application of Ito's formula just says
to us another way to write this is that
the increment of empty in a short time
interval is just some sigma x the in
cremant over Brown in motion this can
also be imagined as a Gaussian of
variance TS and if we try to think about
what m at time T plus DT is equal to M
squared times T plus DT this will be mt
+ DM t square which is empty square plus
2 I just open the brackets empty dmt so
this thing is just a martin girlfriend
Plus now DMT times the empty unlike in
usual differentiation since I took root
of the S here it'll just give me V T
Sigma T DT sorry right and therefore the
expectation of a m-f time row is just
the expectation of the integral between
0 & row of sigma t square dt when i take
expectation this term just vanishes and
i'm left with this thing so all we care
about is think how fast this martingale
varies right and in order to do this
square sorry yeah I'll get exactly to
the point where this center of mass
fears so in order to do this I want to
look at empty and try to differentiate
it in a smarter way so first of all
let's note that the distribution of w1
conditioned on what happened until time
T is just a normal vector Center that WT
whose standard deviation is 1 root 1
minus T which encourages me to define a
density ft of X to be just the Gaussian
density centered here with this standard
deviation so some normalizing constant
times e to the minus X minus w t square
or to 1 minus T so this is just a family
of dense it is beginning from the
standard Gaussian its center moves
according to a Brownian motion and it's
variants shrink so just imagine some
thing moving again the time one it
becomes a delta measure somewhere by
definition we have that MT is just the
integral over a of ft x DX and in order
to calculate the how empty varies we
want to differentiate this
fint and will actually differentiate
inside the integral so I want to
calculate DFT of X so this is easily
done by Ito's formula and I think what
I'll do is I'll just keep the
calculation and tell you what the result
is so it turns out that what we get here
is this formula
just half a minute to give some
intuition about what happens here so we
see that in a little time increment in
order to move from ft to F T plus DT
what we do is we take ft and we add to
it again ft but x some linear function
right this is just a linear function of
X with a whose gradient is distributed
according to some small normal variable
so basically the process ft is just the
product of many many many many many
linear functions with infinitesimal
gradients and well this kind of does
make sense because if we consider the
one-dimensional case suppose that the
first linear function was 1 plus some
epsilon times X and the second linear
function was 1 minus some epsilon times
X so we have many 1 + + 1 minus s which
kind of cancel out but each such
cancellation gives us 1 minus epsilon
square x squared so a quadratic thing
and if we take if we multiply many many
things like that if we raise that to a
high power what we get is something like
e to the minus X square right so many
many linear functions kind of get a
Gaussian density and well they won't all
cancel each other out the remaining
terms will will give us something like e
to the X right or some exponential
sample which will just move this
enter of this gay option so this may be
a weird way to look at this simple
process but in this context at least it
seems like a rather natural way because
I have five minutes left right okay
great and and now we get to the main
point here right so when I take
something and multiply it by a linear
function and I want to see how it varies
how this integral varies i only care
where the centroid is located right the
integral of something x a linear
function if i put everything in the
sword centroid everything will be the
same so if i wanna measure how fast this
thing varies all i care is how far the
centroid of a with respect to this
measure is from the centroid of this
measure which is at WT now it's any if
if we be if a was a half space in the
beginning then at any point in time well
it will definitely still be a half space
also also if we kind of normalized back
so that this thing become a gap becomes
the Gaussian measure we can always
consider some change of variables which
turns this back into a Gaussian a
standard Gaussian measure sorry so a
will just move but remain a half space
if it started from a half space and the
point is that if i compare any set which
is not a half space with the
corresponding GAAP space which has the
same measure the centroid of the half
space will always be more far away so
i'll just finish with this picture
at least it's it's easy to agree that at
time zero if a looked like this and they
consider the corresponding calf space
whose centre of masses in the same
direction well so if this is a and this
is H the centroid of age will be more
far away from the origin than the
centroid of a because it's always worth
while to take the mass located here and
move it in this direction so at least
for small values of T it's kind of clear
that if I want to maximize the scale of
this thing then I want to maximize the
norm of this vector and then I want to
take the set to be a half space and in
the minus half minute I have left what I
already always say is that there is some
coupling argument that kind of lets lets
me take this principle and carry it to
larger times and well for the robustness
you need a little like some some more
ideas but the point is that if a wasn't
was wasn't close to a half space in the
first place all you all you have to do
is show that it remains far from a half
space for some significant amount of
time and then the process corresponding
to a is kind of lagged behind a
corresponding process for the half space
and I guess I'll finish here
yeah so so the depend I I didn't really
try to optimize this but the dependents
i get is something like the size of a
times the size of well my 1 minus the
size of a and this taken to some power I
don't know 10 or something ah well 10 at
one side and 1-10 at the other let's say
I believe that well up to this constant
this is the correct dependence but I
didn't really I mean I don't really see
an application to trying to optimize
this constant stabilized so your proof
is good for well they're dirt to prove
the majority's stay blessed first of all
you need much less so Joe showed
yesterday a probably much simpler proof
but both what I did here in what Joe did
yesterday lack this component of trying
to understand what the low influences
will give you if you just use this idea
or basically if you just use the
Gaussian stability oh oh oh yeah well
yes so this is exactly actually my
question is so is your proof so if we of
course it is much I mean we are using
its
shooting vulgar shooting but still if
you are considering your idea is it that
like a very different proof idea from
the previous 25 years yeah it's another
story yeah it's it's a no I Mannix it
seems like amen yeah it seems like a
completely new type of general is this
if you're saying it's a video you could
use it I mean the argument here you can
James you can take any any marketing
gear and write the quadratic variation
well that's true but some are it for
this specifically for the GAO chance you
get a process of measures which you can
actually differentiate and and and right
so so the ito differential of this thing
turns out to be a very simple thing well
you could consider so yeah you quit okay
so so maybe I'll just say that there are
versions of this equation where you
could do so so so this disappears in
papers related to things proving things
in different contexts concentration of
measure and convex bodies etc you can't
we could start from this equation where
your initial density was just any given
density and this will give you some
family of measures which were which you
can also add franchi eight but I don't
see how to yeah I am not sure what kind
of results you were hoping to do with
this
you make that up even more than are the
new face of neo space we can take the
mean but here for instance will be so
dizzy if it wasn't in a million within
city yes we are right so so what you
have to know what a linear functionals
but you will have you are as a geodesic
going from the w 22 digs and you have to
take the initial Victor ejection mean
right if I think even that way he we are
getting away from the ocean aspects on
the 32 the Markovian yes yes that's yeah
yeah yeah I ever okay thanks next talk
is a 20 person
Oh